my name is Rowan flavin a faculty member
in the anthropology department here and
I work on archaeology in China and so
what I'm going to tell you a little bit
about today is a prediction method a
divination process that we've used in
early China and in particularly talking
about a period in Chinese history at the
beginning of the dynastic cycle so about
3,500 years ago and its associated with
a dynasty called the shang dynasty have
any of you ever heard of the term oracle
bones oracle bones often bring to mind
whiting and the reason for that is that
the first inscription is known from
china first writing we know from Chinese
context in the first historical
documents we have come from bones like
these and so be the documents that we
have that marked the beginning of the
historical record in China are our
divination records in the most part and
they're records that that document a
series of our questions or issues that
the Shawn Court wanted to know more
information about from the spirit world
around them the inscriptions were first
identified by a aristocrat in that lived
at very end of the 19th century
beginning 20th century named Wang Nehru
and he thought was sick and had some
member of his household go to the
apothecary to get what were sometimes
referred to as dragon bones these were
essentially bones that were found in
archaeological contexts that would then
be ground up into powder and added into
medicine and those powders were thought
to be beneficial to one's health so he
send somebody out they brought back some
bones like this and what we have on here
is an inscription that's a fragment of a
divination record while he wrote
recognized that that this was writing
because he was a scholar himself he
recognized the big war some similar
to the characters that he knew from
archaic context and he started to
compile you buy them up from the pasta
carries around all over the place
we learned a lot about the song based on
these and what we've learned mostly
about is what the song of royalty were
most concerned about and they were
divining about each of these divinations
divination inscriptions has several
different sections they don't all have
it but a complete one has several
different sections it has a date on it
it's very important these are not
absolute dates their dates in a in a
cycle of 60 days so there's a 60 day
cycle and each of these inscriptions
when they're complete will have two
characters at the beginning of it that
mark of the date within the 60-day cycle
then they will tell you about who it is
that was responsible for the divining
and then after that there's there's a
charge there's basically a topic about
which the diviners wanted to know and
then what would have happened is
something is you would have had diviners
who who recorded the dates they recorded
the topic that they were divining about
not on the bones initially then
something they wait to see what happened
and then they record the result and then
all of that is inscribed onto the bones
in certain cases